well we have a very cute friend he has a
blue tongue and no he hasn't been eating
a lot of ice cream or Powerade most
nerves
this little guy is adorable he is a blue
tongue lizard or a Blue Tongue skink
depending and this little guy his name
is bluey and check out that blue team or
blue isn't he cute
so if you'd like look at that tongue
what how close here is that Thursday his
ears actually - those giant holes on the
sides of his head do you want to give
him a little out he feels so soft and
smooth and these guys have found in
Australia look at that tongue so what
he's doing is yeah he's talking to you
but these guys if they want to look big
and tough they open their mouth and kind
of hiss and stick out he doesn't look
that scary right now but watch out is a
little glider these sugar gliders
Australia sugar in Texas they get slept
in a little pouch yeah and they have
that super soft tail you can give him a
little pat if you like right like really
soft like we fell video these guys have
an amazing way of moving around like
live at that time that little flap
between their legs they can glide from
tree to tree they're so smart big guy I
know he kind of has those big eyes kind
of make me not trust him
I'll feed him out of my name already
what he's grabbing your little finger
[Music]
adorable there green tree frogs so these
guys are also Australian and they're
really quite amazing because they're
actually quite large for a frog and I
love how they just chill out once they
find a comfortable perch they just chill
them if I kiss it well it's Pancake he's
so comfortable he loves you so these
guys are incredibly important for the
environment frogs are like environmental
indicators so if there's pollution
climate change pollutants going into the
water and the surrounding environments
they really suffer so if the frogs are
having a hard time you know that
something's wrong you're so cute I mean
if you jumped at me right now right in
there I want to pop up nicely ready and
I'm just gonna okay so what's next next
we have some adorable snakes this one
here a little bit coiled up this is
actually a baby green tree python now
he's a little bit feisty little bit
biting so you hold this one maybe just a
little pat on the end of his tail but
he's actually that fluorescent yellow
and the amazing thing with this is this
is a young one it'll get a lot bigger
it's a Python so when they're full-grown
they're actually bright green and when
they hatch out they can be red yellow
and as soon as they're born he how he's
sticking his tongue out as well yeah
that's because he's smelling new guys
he's like Oh
yeah interesting I can't look at a snake
without thinking of Harry Potter and
they actually don't have any ears so
they can't hear anything so I'm like
yeah it's funny I not know that they can
feel vibrations so if you are singing or
talking or walking around they can feel
it just can't hear it which is amazing
they live in the rainforest too because
there's a whole community that like a
deaf community that works with going to
shows they do that they can do shows
it's a kind of thing and they feel the
vibe they hear music is this an adult
green pipe so you can see what he grows
up into so life see I like this more
powerful exciting hi sweetie
[Music]
and these guys live in the rainforest so
they're incredible at climbing they can
actually stretch from limb to limb
almost their whole body just completely
outstretched incredible core muscles
they're Python in The Jungle Book
these guys are really special yeah
they're awesome like in your hand what's
fantastic is that you can love and
appreciate snakes and you don't have to
cuddle them it's okay you can love them
from a distance but every animal has a
special purpose on the planet we try to
educate everybody this is a beautiful
special a dear beautiful to protect them
in the wild we want to thank you guys
though for being such wonderful wildlife
warriors because being here and talking
about the importance of these beautiful
animals is how we're gonna protect them
indoors that's a thing you'll do right
absolutely yeah we have conservation
projects all over the planet hi buddy
he's gonna come say hi
we have conservation projects all over
the globe so we help with rhinos and
cheetahs in Africa we have a wildlife
hospital that's rescued and
rehabilitated over 80,000 sick
injured and orphaned animals get them
released back alcohol is releasing back
into the wild so I do and here's as well
like everyone at home take your phones
up right now go to Kelly Clarkson show
calm and find out how you can become a
wildlife warriors well with bindi and
Robert and all of them I will not stop
talking until you subscribe to my
youtube channel that's right and I could
talk a lot seriously not gonna stop yep
still here not going anywhere I see you
don't walk away from this